hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the C's the game where
you construct your own vehicle mass
destruction and unleash it on someone or
someone I actually don't really know all
I know is that the screenshots said that
you kind of kill people with your own
machines and that could be found in some
way if I actually know how to play the
game which I don't so I'm hoping to be
learning in the beginning and then
people are gonna get mad at me and I
have no idea what I'm doing
first build some wooden blocks under the
source cube okay oh oh this feels so
natural and inclined I think I'm gonna
build a monstrosity unlike any other I
didn't exactly mean to do that and in
fact I don't actually know what I'm
supposed to be doing
I was an engineer damn it so I'm just
gonna go through pure instinct which if
you ask anyone in engineering school
that's all they really do it anything
they build wow I didn't mean to do that
hey every mistake is a new beginning
what [ __ ] about building ah okay I think
it's like some sort of flying squid
monster okay I'm done place to place
some wheels well most people would
logically place wheels at the bottom I
would probably do the same if I had any
sort of a brain so let's do that
and then some backup wheels over here
just in case and then some triple backup
wheels up here just in case everything
goes wrong which they will that's part
of the design because if happens
unexpectedly then you can't bear for it
but if you're prepared for everything go
wrong and you planned for it to be wrong
then you'll never be surprised anyway
they should vehicle on the ground with
the down-arrow what was that mean
Oh is there a button Oh said the machine
oh okay alright then accelerate using up
and down okay press play I want to play
a game put up those backup wheels I
actually did it I can't believe it and
it looks really pretty
zone conquered that poor farmer I'm
sorry I destroyed all your crops and
family and cows and sheep I think I
heard one getting killed
but hey it's all for progress God
understand that man I'm the guy
appreciate it but we must continue
because progress shall not be stopped
what are you asking me if I need to put
increase my design
probably steering hinge race
the world does that even mean this is a
bunch of baloney my design is perfection
you should not be betraying me for my
incredible design bag oh where you going
hey wait a minute don't run away from
the battlefield you get back to those
chickens you bastard we need to take
down there all right okay
so how do I stop all right then I think
I need to go back to the drawing board
let me destroy that machine yes please
take it away I didn't need it anymore
right so what we're gonna need is we're
gonna lean mean destruction machine
which means we're gonna need a lot of
what I call destruction prongs and the
biggest wooden wooden blocks jutting out
in the front she's gonna be like a I
don't know like have you ever seen
terminator you know how those big mechs
just came out of nowhere and kind of
destroyed everyone yeah that's what this
is gonna be all about kind of maybe not
really not really actually it's not
gonna be anything like that nothing at
all it's gonna be more like it's gonna
be a whole lot and out of that none of
that okay I just need to make sure it's
not you know top-heavy this is where I'm
actually engineering principles kind of
come in handy but uh but this is so easy
to build do all right so now you know
those destruction prongs I told you
about yeah this is gonna happen okay so
this is just gonna jut out it's gonna be
so front heavy that there's no way it'll
stay balanced unless I put some
balancing in the back here this is just
what I call a wake tail it's just not
it's not heavy this is big bone okay
here we go oh that looks natural
I love the undulating style of it let's
just go before things break my design is
flawless I'm an impeccable destructor
take that chicken bastards I don't know
how I did it but I do okay you sow to
use a camera I know how to use the
camera don't ask me middle mouse click
focus on a blocker environment okay
reach Insignia okay screw in and now
I can do this I can do this just cuz I'm
a fork of death doesn't mean I can do it
oh there were bombs though Oh Bob's
everywhere are the Sheep bombs - are
these sheep bombs cheap bombs okay
everything is on fire oh no the poor
sheep exploding into blood okay fine
fine then I will go back I need to make
a I need to make a smaller smaller move
smaller machine okay I got it just hang
on wait a minute okay so we're different
to the fear I need I need a steering
hinge I don't think that's how the
steering ends is supposed to go oh crap
I need to start again okay hang on hang
on hang on I know you're all yelling at
me but just hang on I got this let me
work my mojo
and just like it'll be a front-wheel
drive vehicle I hope I don't know if
this is exactly either supposed to go
and I think I made a little bit too wide
but that don't matter because here we go
cheering oh my vehicle what about you
dick bags oh god damn it stupid sheep
all right so I need a leaner and meaner
is basically what I need to be going for
but smaller instead of leaner and meaner
I need smaller and tinier and also
goddamn four-wheel drive is not very
beneficial
there's a big enough cause it'd be good
enough for me okay yeah yeah oh oh oh
steering don't work side cross well [ __ ]
okay why did the Sheep want to attack me
I'm gonna be here forever okay lean and
mean machine version - this one's really
gonna get it because it's got more
maneuverability and it's also got more
killing miss miss miss this house a tree
Oh get away from me you damn sheep oh
okay did I kill them all am I still
intact
okay Oh everything blew up and
everything failed hi thanks sheep I
think this can actually work hands great
I can do this I just need to take the
long road away wow that's not what I
wanted don't attack me you cheap
bastards I'm gonna go the long way
around
you suck dong I'll see you when I get
back
don't don't mind me at all don't mind
don't don't mind me don't mind me wait
han [ __ ] damn it you son of a [ __ ] just
steer correctly no not in the mine why
didn't the work how are you even turning
that much with your wheels that's
incredible but also screw you no okay
just turn no stop god damn you the trick
is just to make very small adjustments
with my Turner's because otherwise it's
going to cause horrible havoc and and
plague and disease and everyone's gonna
die just look at them all dying over
there that's all because of what I've
done in my previous designs oh yeah
success Nexus own what do you got for me
perimeter wall oh you sons of [ __ ]
oh you sassy sous are you gonna get it
out don't even think about it
I have more
more oh I have so much more I didn't
know that I had so much more oh I'm so
much more killing things to destroy
people with why don't I just go around
what could it why could I not just go
around you guys
how could I kill you but why why would I
why would I subject myself to this hang
on okay bye
don't worry about me you don't see
doctors do you huh
what huh I'm I'm a lean mean driving
machine look at me
Hey look at me Hey look at me look at me
Hey look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me
destroying your [ __ ] look at me oh my
[ __ ] sky getting destroyed - hey let me
just wrap up here [ __ ] I did it I killed
them all I'm so happy with my life I'm
so happy with the choices that oh this
bad ah the Queen's fodder okay this is
gonna take some real thinking so give me
two seconds on this one oh man oh this
is getting it so this is getting this is
getting rather complicated but I love it
anyway oh man how do I even do this oh
this is turning out great
I love it God is so cool it's like an
engineer's dream okay okay I think I'm
done all right let me put it on the
ground here how do I save this I want to
save it so badly I want to call this the
kill death in a tour
five thousand five not five thousand not
enough space for that okay so what it's
got its got a plow in the front you know
for tilling the fields for when you kill
everyone and they fertilize the soil
you got flamers for turning them to ash
because volcanic ash is very good for
tilling the fields and creating crops
it's got armor plating to protect these
farming equipment this is a farming
equipment by the way the kill detonator
is not a machine of murder
it is a farming tool it's got these
plows on the side which will spin and
rotate and till the soil very
effectively flamethrowers on the side
for decoration armor plating for
protection against wolves cannons up top
for decoration and extra riah fourth
brace everywhere and this lovely turbine
in the back that generates power from
wind so
100% green and fuel-efficient all right
let's go oh my god I did not do that
I didn't even press go Oh No
the kill designator I'm taking 15
minutes really I didn't know that one
piece is going to town oh no I know I
did how could I have known it was
supposed to be a farming tool I would
have got next
all right ooh that looks fun but either
way I'm all out of time for this episode
this was a ton of fun and I can imagine
there's all sorts of chaos that could be
wrought from this type of game so let me
know if you guys want to see more of
this game in the comments below because
if you want more I will gladly play more
but only if you guys want to see more
because I know there's a lot more chaos
to ensue in the future so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the siege I think it's on Steam I'm not
sure how much it is I didn't check it
was probably pretty expensive compared
to most of the games that are I play on
here but hey Todd Steve check it out if
you want to it's a lot of fun thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
this shouldn't be this epic is so
simplistic
[Music]